NOW.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARSON
TONIGHT.
DURING A ROUNDTABLE WITH ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
YESTERDAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK
A QUESTION ABOUT THE GANG MS-13.
AS HE HAS BEFORE, THE PRESIDENT
EXPRESSED HIS THOUGHTS ON THE
SUBJECT BLUNTLY.
>> President Trump: WE ARE
TAKING PEOPLE OUT OF THE
COUNTRY, YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE
HOW BAD THESE PEOPLE ARE.
THESE ARE NOT PEOPLE.
THEY ARE ANIMALS.
>> Tucker: IF ANYTHING, THAT'S
A MILD DESCRIPTION.
DOGS ARE ANIMALS AND A LOT OF
THEM SLEEP ON THE BED.
YOU WOULDN'T WANT TO BE ANYWHERE
NEAR MS-13.
AND HUMAN BEINGS, YOUNG GIRLS.
UNLIKE ANIMALS, THEY KILL FOR
FUN, OFTEN WITH MACHETES.
THEY TERRORIZE THE POOR AND THE
VULNERABLE AND HAVE MADE
EL SALVADOR THE MOST DANGEROUS
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
THERE IS LITERALLY NO DEFENDING
THEM AND YET, THE LEFT IS
DEFENDING THEM.
THE PRESIDENT'S ATTIC BOAT TRUMP
LASHED OUT AT UNDOCUMENTED
MEETING CALLING THOSE TRYING TO
BREACH THE COUNTRY'S BORDERS,
ANIMALS.
OVER JEFF BEZOS' VANITY
PUBLICATION, THERE WAS THIS.
TRUMP EVOKES A DUMB LIKE AN UGLY
HISTORY OF DEHUMANIZATION.
SO THE PRESIDENT IS A FOR
CRITICIZING A VIOLENT STREET
GANG.
FOR HER PART OVER AT THE HOUSE,
NANCY PELOSI RACED TO THE
NEAREST MICROPHONE TO DEFEND THE
DIGNITY OF MS-13.
WATCH THIS.
>> THERE IS A SPARK OF DIVINITY
AND EVERY PERSON ON EARTH.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES SAYS ABOUT
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS, THESE
ARE NOT PEOPLE, THESE ARE
ANIMALS, YOU HAVE TO WONDER,
DOES HE NOT BELIEVE IN THE SPARK
OF DIVINITY, THE DIGNITY OF
EARTH AND EVERY PERSON?
EVERY DAY, YOU THINK YOU HAVE
SEEN IT ALL AND ALONG COMES
ANOTHER MANIFESTATION OF WHY
THEIR POLICIES ARE SO INHUMANE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT JUST
DISHONEST THOUGH, OBVIOUSLY.
IT'S A LUNATIC.
WHY WOULD THE LEFT TO BE
DEFENDING THE COUNTRY'S MOST
VIOLENT STREET GANGS?
TRUMP HAS MADE THEM IRRATIONAL
AS PART OF IT, BUT THE LEFT ALSO
SENSES A THREAT TO ITS BASIC
WORLDVIEW.
IT'S A LIVING REMINDER THAT THE
LEFT'S POSITION ON IMMIGRATION
IS A LIE.
THEY TELL YOU EVERY DAY THAT THE
IMMIGRANT IS A FUTURE BRAIN
SURGEON OR TECH FOUNDER,
THEREFORE CONTROL IS
UNNECESSARY.
AND, MOST PEOPLE SEND THEIR
PEOPLE HERE, AND THEY ARE NOT
THE BEST.
SOME OF THEM ARE GREAT, SOME ARE
THOUGH AND SOME JOINT MS-13.
THE SAME BECAUSE PEOPLE AREN'T
ALL THE SAME.
THAT'S THE POINT OF THE
IMMIGRATION LAW.
THEY ARE NOT THE SAME AND WE
SHOULD SORT THE GOOD FROM THE
BAD.
LEFT, I WOULD SUGGEST THIS MIGHT
BE A REAL COUNTRY WHOSE ACTUAL
CITIZENS HAVE INTERESTS WORTH
PROTECTING.
YESTERDAY ON TWITTER, THE
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN WENT AFTER
THE PRESIDENT'S VIEWS ON
IMMIGRATION AND ENDED HIS TWEET
THIS WAY: "WE THE CITIZENS OF
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD, ARE NOT IMPRESSED."
CITIZENS OF THE ECONOMY COME UP
THAT IT ALL.
TO THE MODERN LEFT, YOU ARE NOT
UN-AMERICAN WITH CULTURE AND
HISTORY AND COLLECTIVE IDENTITY.
YOU ARE A CITIZEN OF THE
ECONOMY, A COG IN THE MACHINE OF
GLOBAL CAPITALISM.
AMERICA IS JUST ANOTHER PRIVATE
EQUITY SCHEMED TO SOME.
THEIR PLEDGE IS DIFFERENT THAN